now what is a metaphor a metaphor is not
the same as the thing itself a metaphor
is the standard it is not the problem
itself a metaphor is not a simile it's
something else so the metaphor for a
lonely boy is not a lonely boy there's a
metaphor for an unattractive girl not an
unattractive girl it's something like
the metaphor I like the problem but not
the problem itself a metaphor is
something that stands apart from the
problem yet is somehow linked to its
secret it's like two wires and when
you're theme and your metaphor are lined
up right Sparks will go back and forth
you have the problem and the metaphor
and they have to get close enough for a
spark to jump across the wires cannot
touch and if they're too far apart
there'll be no spark and if they're on
top of each other there'll be no swear
but you you get them like this and then
also you tip them a little bit
feel the Spartan the metaphor has to
just come close enough that there's
going to be a spark so you have to tease
them and and play with the spark so that
yellow taxi cab is a metaphor for
loneliness